right well this is what we've all been  waiting for  a free class  goat yoga  it's being offered tonight at silverado  ranch park now that's near the corner of  silverado and las vegas boulevard right  behind the south point casino so if you  have some free time and you have some  you know goat kibble everyone's welcome  it's free on a first come first serve  basis classes are being put on by goat  yoga las vegas  all right boy that is great form right  there uh it's happening tonight as we  said silverado ranch park from 5 30  until 7  30. get your goat yoga on everybody that  takes skill it's your day pull the pose  with a four-legged animal running around  making noise a very patient goat to pose  for that photo too